[Music]
welcome to another dozen psychology but
to have 71 years I hope you're all
staying home I so I wanted to show as
much as puzzles I like as I can today
because I'm so far in our chess and
psychology classes we've talked about
games a lot and we talked about how to
think and the preparation and stuff so
today I wanted to give some puzzles so
we could see how to apply those and try
and find the best moves
so yeah let's starts I'll be reading the
chats from my phone so I might see it
and I'll respond to it verbally most
likely so yeah let's dive in this is the
first position blacks to move some what
might be too easy if it's too easy we
have harder ones prepared too
so basically the way I think about it
most of these puzzles are about you find
out what you want to do and then you
realize how why the opponent's isn't
letting you and like how the opponent is
blocking that idea and then you find a
way to fix it pretty much so it's not as
a straightforward
so far I only have one such a suggestion
so far I don't see the corrective and
thank you Tracy for the suggestion
hmm I owe someone said it
oh hello Aram wait I don't think that's
the arm that I know um it's not the same
faculty I it's where it's working for me
if you are the same our own say
something like Webster or something I
have one person so far who has said it
correctly
oh they are haha well
so a lot of you are saying the moves
that are going to happen soon but I
don't really see the exact
okay two people upset it so far I'll
give it another minutes before I give
some hints so usually the way that's
easier to think about is to think well
that would be my Siri is to think about
first of all checks and see what's wrong
with the check why wouldn't it work and
then think about takes and then again
why wouldn't that work and then think
about moves with threats all right yeah
I have a lot of people who are saying it
now close
yeah so for example Nichols tell us I
think maybe give me a full line
okay yeah master Hemi gave a full-line
cool so yeah that's pretty much the idea
you wanted to bring your rook and well
if it doesn't take then Bishop three is
also coming and if then Bishop f3 Queen
h2 is the next nope so well not that but
it worked extra special f3 and queen f1
cool ready for next one
[Music]
you
so this one is white to move again think
about checks first and figure out what's
wrong and the check is good enough for
it
yeah this puzzles are tricky told you
where did my viewers go and had a
hundred-plus
so maybe yeah send out some suggestions
on what are the moves that you're
thinking about
and we can go from there
okay so far I'm getting some good
suggestions
so yeah well the idea is that I've been
talking a lot about psychology so far so
today we wanted to give like it really
called the home quiz take home exam I
mean everything is there coming online
this day so I can't wait to see how my
organic chemistry exams will turn out
but yeah so we wanted to figure out how
you guys can apply those so I've seen
some good suggestions for example the
the line that team priests oh yeah cool
that mine actually was correct but dig a
little deeper cuz check you don't really
have to take or you don't have to take
with the the rook
the line the Tracy just gave is also
correct but so let's think about it this
should be five check the things that you
definitely have to consider are the
three takes eight a crook take and queen
take because specialty seven well it's
already kind of game over so yeah so
Bishop b5 isn't it the first move
now you can think about what if the
opponent takes with the pawn because Tim
already said the rook now relief Queen
it shouldn't be that hard just I mean I
just want someone to say the line
yeah all right Ryan said it let's move
on because basically yeah check if you
take what the palm your queen falls if
you take with the rook that's kind of
like the trigger your line and this
Queen c7 is the finishing touch and if
you just take what the Queen just Knight
takes and you are you have more material
and you this should get the job done
cool let's go to the next one
this one is also white tulle oh this one
is actually nice I think I've shown this
one to someone before
oh yeah
so this one is a little trickier the way
I like I recommended to think about it
was to think about it so what's big
biggest problem in blacks position the
King that's in the corner right so in
this situation the King goes in corner
the bishop is controlling the g8 they
run away score but you can't really mate
right now so you need to find the move
that's helps the I don't want to give
out the room to move so so said oh no
floor
well if you know what don't say it for
like a minute or two and let's give
everybody a chance to take a look at it
maybe
or how so many people saying it right
now that's cool
so Angelo is right and that's is one of
the lines that works pretty much the
main line that works because the problem
is so if after ninety seven you have to
take it because if you don't take it
you're history and your mate so you take
it to the bishop and this ninety seven
files you just enough time to actually
bring out the rook and attack this
Knight more and the mate is pretty much
in a bed up in a pitiable I can't say
the word um so now think what it Bishop
e6 it's actually thinking but it would
make more sense when you're thinking
about its beforehand to try and find the
best hopes for black because this is
literally the best move for black which
white still should be able to get the
job done because even if you try to run
it to stalemate and you take it's still
mate
so that one that one is a good one I
like that that's one of my favorite
puzzles to show all right this one is
black steamer off
oh it's actually nice so yeah I keep
thinking about the ideas we've talked
about so far training yourself to think
about checks and takes so you don't miss
a simple mate or a simple capture
yeah I was kind of going for like
hundred fifty to one hundred but next
time
Brian I think you mean night before and
that's one of the ideas that he should
keep you should work on I flip the board
so f2 that I'm getting suggestions would
be c7
okay so Patrick is saying what Patrick
is saying is true so someone just give
me the line cuz I think you all are
thinking about it
what rent
all right so I have different people
saying it correctly burnt tanks for the
line yeah so first you take it with the
rook that you're not going to use to
mate and then after take now you give
the cheque it's a fork so even if you
try to run away your queen falls so you
take okay it's perfect
thank you for all of you who found it
and thought about it and just well of my
108 viewers thank you
tell your friends to get here all right
this one is why to move this is also
very simple because right now you have a
choice to take on e6 and just whoa oh no
it's shut then move wait why can't I
just take care ah the problem is because
it's chosen of so this puzzle kind of
didn't work
but I'll just I'll just tell you what I
think about it so this one the idea is
that basically if you take on e6 you
will have a you'll definitely I mean
you're better and you'll probably have
it you're waiting for Lin and it
shouldn't be that hard to win but if you
want a more clean win which you should
always try to have the cleanest ways to
win Dirk f7 is the move to think about
and when they when he would take here
just plain out of five the if rooky 894
and the e6 rock falls and it's much much
more clear to win this rather than
disposition so that's the basic idea to
try and train yourself to always wants
the the cleanest way to win and the way
that gives your opponents the least
chances so yeah that was basically it
and all right so this one is white you
move this one should also be pretty
doable fast so I'll give everybody about
a minute
so yeah I keep thinking about those
checks and takes first before you
suggest other moves because if they
don't work then yes thank you what other
moves but you don't want to miss some
opportunity with checks and takes
all right so far two people have said it
it is why it's a move
all right yeah you guys found it perfect
so yes you take first the problem is if
he takes if the opponent takes back just
the queen falls so if he decides to take
your queen you have this double check
and then just simple mate so yeah good
job
all right this one is also whitetail
it's kind of it's a slightly harder than
the ones I've son seen so far because
it's not supposed to be as clear and it
takes a bit more calculation so yeah
good luck I'll be right here
all right so so far a lot of the people
have set their right move but I would
prefer to if you give me actual line so
I can say yes these people have found it
not just the one
oh thank you
Nixon thank you
you're gonna hear loud bang soon
probably
and then Simon to the rescue yeah
oh man clutch Nixon yeah thanks nice
tilted
thank you for those writing in Farsi I'm
reading it
okay so I have a line okay
Bishop f6 so you are right about g6
because just take take and clean your
six gets the job done so Bishop f6 the
two main lines that I think you should
think about are the rook taking and the
others were coming to a7 to protect g7
square
so Patrick okay you're telling the Queen
age six again 3k7
cleaner six is the correct move but
maybe try to find the best move for
black too and keep going from there
because your position is better and you
should be able to win this but it's
easier if you try and train yourself to
not only think about your best moves but
your opponent best moves too so you're
better prepared for it before making a
move
yeah so Patrick coin f8 is correct what
would you do after Queen f8
so I'm gonna do the first move because
I'm not sure everybody are following so
Bishop f6 is the first moving is correct
so now the two lines that we were
thinking this should be prepared for is
first of all taking and rook up
so far again through k7 we've agreed on
Queen and six and after Queen of eight
we are thinking what should white do
I think
problem with drug h3 if after queen of
fate is that the rook f6 can work so the
line that I'm talking about is Roque
seven finish six queen of eight if Rukia
tree rook takes on f6 and then if Queen
age seven king of the King runs away
from f7 and the g7 pawn is being
protected by the Queen there should
still be some white still should be able
to keep fighting on this game but black
black gets the easier game and it's
unnecessary to give up your bishop for
free
what book do I recommend for puzzles I
I've been doing online puzzles for a few
years now so I haven't really done book
puzzles in a while let's see I sigh I
really like doing this book it's called
26000 I it's like in games and strategy
I really like doing that when I started
doing it when I and when I got through
that my rating had a cute jump and but
that's I don't actually know if that's a
like a book physical book more but it's
a chess base there's a chess based
version of it
okay I think Iruka a seven might be a
little hard to find before knowing every
single entre kept six so maybe let's
think about rook takes f6 first
we'll come back to rock a seven right
after we finish this line because this
line is a slightly easier more forced so
you're probably going to take this
anyways and King will have to go to a
chit because if King goes to f8 short
rook g8 should be winning enough I think
there's there better options too but
retreat should be enough to win this
game and if King goes to h8 now what's
the move you would do
I think you have made entry regardless
of what as soon as you find this move
I will show you okay seven right after
but tricky seven is the more tricky line
and I just wanted to get the easier line
out of the way
all right so Joe was right yeah Queen g5
so after Queen g5 black has
realistically two ways to try and defend
with rook g6 and Raquel fades so Raquel
fate is easier someone tell me what
would you do we can stroke a fate
yes Patrick Urich takuan g5 is better
than clean g2
all right sorry unfound that's all right
a lot of people found it cool freakish
seven taken meats perfect so instead of
rocket eats what if the trip goes to g6
and after this we can go back to Route
87
all right yeah I have many people saying
it right now so yeah you do take it if
the Queen takes it's pretty easy you
just give the check and eat the Queen
happy endings and if the pawn takes it
tweener sixes should be winning enough
great
yeah so let's go back to the original
position after Bishop f6 rook a7 we
agreed on Queen h6 queen of 8 and now we
already talked a little about yokum's
coming to h3 so let's think about what's
wrong with I I did say what's wrong with
Turkish street so maybe let's think
about something a little bit more simple
because black is kind of stuck right now
and there's nothing wrong with just
keeping the pressure
so the problem with registry was that
after working straight Rock f6 and the
King kind escapes a little because Queen
your 7 king of 7 and you don't really
have a clear winner
and that's why that's what's wrong with
your history because the f6 Bishop is
kind of hanging oh I have someone saying
it's me two people have said it
oh wait we're a third one
no no Joe why are you changing your
answer and Anthony you are right but if
you play 90 to recap six is still
something that you should be careful
about
yeah all right so everybody are saying
most people are thinking about it this
should be fighters don't move that you
can play and yeah the idea is that you
simply want to bring your knight or even
just bring the rook whoops
so yeah Bishop e5 is the critical move
because it's a simple move and while
you're on the high of attacking
sometimes you just miss the simple moves
and you end up giving your opponent
chances to escape and it's very
important to always keep your cool and
try and find the best moves for the
position not just because you feel like
you're attacking and there should be
something oh yeah there should be
something but don't forget about
strategy and positional game while
you're doing the dynamic stuff cool so
black pretty much you can only try and
maybe play King it rates to maybe have
some ideas with I actually don't know if
how black can get out of this because
black is like really super stuck so it's
right now it's up to you you have your
opponent's stock you can either bring
out the knight or you can just play your
cage free and it should be just enough
so yeah this was a cool puzzle I like
this one ready for next whoa ah this is
an easy one you should be having fun
with this
remember keep thinking about checks and
trapping Kings and stuff
yeah I have people saying it cool so
I'll just give it another 30 seconds
before we move on to the next one
so before the thinking about a move such
as rugby 5 which is should be a good
move it's better to always think about
takes and checks first checks and takes
and make sure that there's nothing there
because if you miss the check and mister
take then it's gonna haunt you for a
while yeah I have a lot of people saying
it's awesome so yeah you do take and
after King takes Bishop c5 is the pretty
pretty cool you're just keeping the king
over here and next move you're gonna
play your K 3 and voila
Oh sounds nice too
uh okay so this one is also white you
move and it might be a little harder
well it's it takes more calculation
definitely than the last one
I would suggest you think about checks
first and when you see its if it doesn't
work then think about it takes and then
if that doesn't work I know I'm saying
it a lot but I just really want that to
be try and become habits all right yeah
so the first thing that comes to mind is
rupee 7 or Bishop d7 or some stuff like
that so think about that and maneuver
around that
so if you're suggesting like Patrick
like you think you should play with p7
preferably give me a line because Rick
p7 well black is going to take with the
bishop and the big question is what are
you gonna do next
yeah the bishop is better to stay on a
six-year
yeah Patrick your rights so give me a
line
okay so yeah I'm getting some good lines
yes if after rugby one Bishop takes a
sex
quint I take six Kings seven rupees so
yeah that is a correct line but what if
after rook p1 Bishop e6 is not necessary
what if your opponent just plays rook d7
so I'm gonna make that line I mean put
it on the board
truck p1 rook d7 so my question is how
will you proceed so right now it's where
it's getting a little tricky
well the problem is that after rook t7
you can't just wait around because Queen
b5 Bishop takes a second Queen a6 just
King goes to d8 and that's it you just
or a rook down
yeah so you do take it in the Queen
takes and so now the problem well
ideally you would want to play c6 but
you can't because of the knight on e5 so
the first thing that you should the
first thing you should think about a
special takes p7 and then you realize
that that doesn't work because just
retakes and then the second thing you
could think about is c6 and then that
also doesn't work because of Knight
takes c6 and then the third thing you
should think about it specially v and
think if that works and if it doesn't
work as well as it should
what why is that
yeah but if Bishop e5 black has a very
nice move and I don't want to say it
without everybody having a thought about
it yes there should be five would work
if work didn't have this move so now
maybe it's a good idea for everybody to
think about which it takes e5 if F takes
c5 c6 you're winning
great but what if Bishop takes e5 to try
and find the best move for black
oh yeah so the prophets did do a good
prophecy
I guess that troops might walk alright
so this should be five king dat yeah
okay I have a bunch of other people
taking you out King da so yeah you take
King et8
is the reason Bishop e5 wouldn't work
the best as it should because now this
mate it's coming and you can try and
play like h3 f4 stuff and just take take
and recreate and why this is still
better and whites can keep fighting for
a win but black is kind of slipping away
so that's why here after Queen b7 now
you know what is wrong with the should
be 5 think about a better way to
approach this problem
so you know that your first rank is the
problem think about fixing that
so I'm getting a lot of Queen B fives so
clean me five is it doesn't really do
you that that's much good because well
you you are keep like working on the c6
idea I assume oh yeah but the c6 idea
was pretty cool and the King d8 doesn't
work anymore because of take and so I
was thinking what if simply take over
here
and just King d8 26
this should be working but so the way
that they went about it in the game was
they put each tree which is like one of
those show moves that you would never
think about with love an attack when
you're a rock down in a million years
but the idea is if the King tries to
round you just take and now you have
Queen 86 and you are attacking the c6
and so I think that's pretty cool and I
kind of liked that idea so I yeah so
this puzzle was pretty cool let's see
what's next one oh this one is nice and
should be pretty easy so this one is
black see move I think this might be our
last one depending on how fast we can do
it so yeah this is black so move and try
to figure out what's the problem and how
you can fix it basically and always try
to when you look at a position try to
figure out what are your weaknesses what
are your opponent's weaknesses and try
to fix those
so somebody did say these three oh cool
about 121 can be reached 150
I know next next week
I don't know how the ladies might just
kind of work
I'm not concerned with that because I'm
not concerning myself at that
should we put it for the all-girl class
online you [ __ ] guy Texas kick him
out no kidding I'll tell you what
happens to the wine and cheese that's my
main question yeah maybe you get some
wine and cheese but everybody I'm
thinking is that every class that we
stream could be our last for a month
yeah I mean a lot of the so most I don't
I don't think most but some of the
states near Missouri have done shutdowns
for restaurants and bars for now that's
happening in st. Louis City and County
Oh cheers to this
but it's like I'm kind of I'm like so if
when they do that the awesome shutdown
which will happen soon enough I'm gonna
give it two to three weeks before
everybody's like set in your homes you
go let me shoot you or give you a ticket
so I guess it's pretty much the same at
this point yeah I'm kind of I'm there's
no one here at this club except for me
you and ro and I mean if you give me a
piece of South loose Chess Club I can
hang it in my room and sit on the window
give me a flag go hang it on my dorm the
one in my doors but people are throwing
parties and I'm like use this still
slick
god
oh I'm having some cool answers all
right yeah I think so far two people
that three people haven't four people
have mentioned it's cool we got a fifth
one all right I'm saying it so the idea
is that you realize that your opponent
has done a sacrifice that doesn't work
very well and you want to take advantage
of that so the first thing you could
think about are the checks and four
should be this should be one of the
things you think about even though it
doesn't work because of just queen takes
and you made it
you when you keep that in mind you
realize that circuitry for works because
if I take with the Queen now this works
and I eat your queen and if I don't take
with the Queen and take back whoops with
with the rook the first rank is weak and
this this works so yeah the other thing
that you should think about is yeah
reflux you for what if Bishop takes g7
well you kind of have to take it back
and you are simply a rook up because
there are no professionals there now
man miracle takes just even check here
you're just run away with the King and
everything is pretty defended check just
King up or even King f8 should work I
don't want to risk it I like King huge
seven yeah this should perfectly work
and yeah
let's see is there anything else well
just maybe don't play okay seven cuz of
Queen of fate
I don't think White has professional but
even if White's finds a miracle which I
but but I don't think there is this is
just purely winning direction for is the
mood as your physician needs so
regardless of what White has this is the
this is a move that you should play and
if white manages to pull something off
well you did your best and why did their
best so you should be happy about that I
think I gotta take off cuz Daraa is
gonna come talk about end games possibly
we're having some big sink issues so
maybe we'll have that class and maybe we
won't hopefully in just a few moments
all right so I am glad we all had yeah
I'm glad you guys had fun hopefully you
know it's fun
and hopefully we'll still keep the
classes going for next week otherwise
I'll have to be talking with masks and
gloves from hospital I'm just kidding
Santos isn't that bad right now so just
stay safe I want to say wash your hands
but I feel like that's becoming a cliche
these days yeah if you see a Liezel just
take it because everywhere everywhere is
like we drove around for like an hour
and we found two wisel's and you're very
proud of that so stay safe wash your
hands
eat sleep do chess chess is the only
game that you can actually continue
doing online so see you next week
[Music]
Oh
[Music]